Wolfpac what is the Wolfpack Oh Rob what
the [ __ ]
I got this ramen I'm gonna have a hood
pass to get that
that's a type of sampler
I need that Oh
yeah
okay I did today
Rubick italiano
a lot of fat to attune
it's really good
you know we have the micro here now
so for me I love Mexican food but
it's funny because even though we're in
my LA light I can sort of like the heart
of escorting it like commenting on that
pic like straight up street art Mexican
food
we were walking by here I saw a whole
dead pig the best rate of Mexico so but
we want to try it out we obviously have
our basics which is our carne asada
right everybody loves us on it it's
super limey it's grilled whatever
whatnot
this guy grabbed this I don't know what
the [ __ ] going on
what do you brought taco to my face
balls like that language taken Bob he
grabbed us and now we're trying on
different parts of the pig so
this right here just a pile of [ __ ] is
actually being tested for repast so
literally try that out over here
and this is fixed now
very gelatinous you really spin like now
when I had mixed number form X color was
deep-fried and crunchy so I don't know
what this gonna taste like
over here we have the red meat
and last but not least
what is that
what it was the portrait oh this was the
part
did we don't know
brought that's yours
for little tensional fresh much
I'm gonna go with the tomatillo
and a nice squeeze of lime you ready Rob
Cheers
salut it has an inner lining tastes like
the inside of a pig's butt hole but if
you like like that barnyard love me
metallic you taste the things and you
kind of like this so is anybody who
likes liver these reminiscent of that
but actually a lot more mild
I think David you enjoyed so much he's
pretty stressed out don't be a [ __ ]
your name is [ __ ] Dirty Sanchez what
does it taste like you
first I was thinking of like Papa Joe
chumpy but then like a philic now I say
stuff like are you like like tendon and
tripe and all the other stuff though now
I don't even ask for that
yeah I can't attend it it's right though
I can't eat that [ __ ] I hate that
so usually all my Cambodian friends love
that [ __ ] yeah cuz that's all yeah
so hard
we're gonna eat the snap yeah
you'll have to eat the whole thing
though okay he's bitching damn this is
heavy
the nose oh my god it's so gooey
when I had to snap it was really good
because it was deep-fried and crunchy
this is like brain - this is correct
Rob I'm giving you the sparkle
cheers Cheers Hawking hold up
yeah choose that taco
blammo wise if you like pork fat you
like this but
we got the notes and a lot of collagen
in it
and it had like a very stiff detection
to it so if you've ever had like tendon
tendon had a lot of collagen and tooth
those and I'd like this see if you try
to see it my fingers are kind of
sticking together
that's the collagen in the nose so
that's the tissues that you're getting
if you can't eat that I don't know what
it is fine but I need like
flavor good textures a little off I feel
like I just bit into the ass I'm a fat
fat person
and astray the fat guys
asada
thank God horses on you know I robbed
take that right on top
we're excited even the review
palatable for questions born American
super-good taught us always bomb the
other guy who didn't speak any English
at all here another goofy bomb it was
confident too it's like you'll have
these you already know [ __ ] all right
if it like a man
I'm allergic to pork I'm Jewish I'm
Jewish like just chewing this is the
pork rib
this one's like a good fight
I think it was a Sackler Vietnam
he's very lean so I'll take some of this
out and put into the roast pork to have
that little back to it
there's a stationary korean compound
which is a beef bone marrow soup I
[ __ ] hated it every year my mom would
make a big ol thing of it right and
every [ __ ] year she would feed it to
me she goes eat this I don't know she
would why it makes me throw up
I've been throwing up every year since
you made it but she goes you don't know
what good food is trying or I'm gonna
beat your ass I would eat it out with
Yap on the table she goes
why'd you tell me you remember luck
a couple moments ago some of the story
speeds because I'm not gonna be a [ __ ]
I do you guys